bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo
video sono fa vigente oggi siamo su
sixties presidente ragazzi allora è un
gioco che mi hanno consigliato in me
l'avete consigliato voi alcuni youtubers
me l'ha consigliato mia nonna
probabilmente tutti mi avete niente lega
la cosa molto semplice previte facciamo
new game praticamente ragazzi io sono
solo quest'uomo che bello che sono tra
l'altro che bella che sei anche tu sia
mangiate un po meno dal mac è solo
questo sessanta secondi ragazzi per
raccogliere più oggetti possibile non
per pesarli e per buttarli loro 8 gen
caso si raccolgono mano sinistra
devo prendere più cose possibili in 60
secondi e buttarle dentro rifugio anche
questo incluso mia sorella
ecco credo fosse mia mia moglie non lo
so rientro tesoro brava così tanto ce
l'ho lanciata proprio manco fosse un
barile prendi tua figlia veloce che
cazzo a mia figlia vale 3 vale di più e
perché obeso il gela lascia lascia
prendi lascia prendi lascia anche mio
figlio ho un figlio che bello che tuo
figlio devo fare i complimenti buttalo
giù tutti i morti
prendi la truffa premia zuppa che serve
ai preservativi non ce la faccio la
gabbia preservativi buttati giù e come
faccia entrare
si ok ok home sweet home perfetto stata
l'esplosione nucleare l'abbiamo fatta
non so come ma ce l'abbiamo fatta
perfetto dimenticati preservati non si
scappa fatemi capire un attimo come
siccome si gioca adesso devo prendere
lascia abbiamo il fucile abbiamo lascia
abbiamo la maschera antigas adegua ok
tutti quanti ce l'abbiamo fatta dentro
rifugio un secondo prima delle
esplosioni che siamo insieme possiamo
far sì che le cose funzionino qui sotto
il nostro rifugio e pieno di barattoli
noi mangiamo dai barattoli dormiamo con
i barattoli e a volte parliamo che il
baratteri è certo abbiamo solo
necessario di acqua per tutti quanti e
quindi abbiamo relazioni molto ristrette
perfetto tempo delle razioni ok cosa ci
rimane è la madonna quanto zu potevo
lasciar morire mia figlia tanto era
obesa è una roba veramente una tristezza
sono rimasti sotto quel giorno 2
perfetto hanno citofonato ragazzi
scusate un attimo era la pizza la gara
la pizza ok perfetto mancava la pizza
come rifornimento in un gioco così
perfetta un regalo fai
ok ma devo razionale coeva che cazzo ne
so io di te lo vedevo dall'aura baia gli
stronzi qua che non mangiano prova a
dargli da mangiare stavolta e da bere a
tutti siamo partire per una spedizione
stasera spedizione roma 6 set i cadeaux
chiaramente al di fuori che chi vuoi
mandare fuori mandiamo il papa dai non
solo il papa a vedere che il cazzo
succede ma lo posso comandare mentre
fuori giorno quanto noi è uscito la sua
sono andato pure a [ __ ] perfetto e tu
non lo sai doveva tuo marito a farsi le
[ __ ] radioattiva ed se n'è andato il
superficie del chiamo di rivederlo
presto alla madonna che diario di bordo
tanto diamo del cibo a tutti quanti
tranne attende che tornerà che non ci
sarà più un cazzo stata un'altra
esplosione nucleare abbiamo bisogno di
prendere qualche cosa prima che tutto
vada prezzi comunque tendono è ancora
tornato manco per il caso c'è una zuppa
aperta mi sa che il padre è morto perché
era fuori quando c'è la l'esplosione
benissimo perfetto
ragazzi ho finito l'acqua disponibile
non posso darla tutti allora facciamo
morire prima la [ __ ] fare quei
seduti con praticamente nulla ci sta
portando alla pazzia di omino diventano
una roba pazzesca di dario mai non c'è
più case da dare da bere il resto
portare qualcosa come giochi o robe per
intrattenerli ma non ho portato un cazzo
tra nella zuppa bilanciate via zuppa
giocato un po a lancia la zuppa è
tornato te diventi in gran forma come
style ed è ritornato dal suo viaggio
nella superficie come ha fatto a
sopravvivere abbiamo guadagnato più una
zuppa più un'acqua perfetto siamo
distribuire un po d'acqua mary jane da
la richiesta per tutto il giorno senti
mary jane un po meno cazzia dolores
tempo tranquilla erede diventato infetto
con qualcosa tende molto stanco sentite
muori cibo per tutti grazie a dio
oggi si mangia tutti chi va fuori allora
mandiamo dallo zio vai che ti vedo bello
carico non c'è più un cazzo regalate da
una fame della madonna e non c'è più un
cazzo perfetto mi dispiace ragazzi mi
manca il cibo e cosa dobbiamo fare
sono tempi difficili abbiamo finito la
nostra certa qual e cena cosa avete
mangiato topi e non ci sono niente un
caso mi spiace non posso intrattenervi
regali dovete morire così
giorno 11 era progettato questo rifugio
è stato un genio ma non sappiamo se
quella roba verde scende dal tubo era
inclusa e vabbé non pensi giorno 30 il
figlio non è torno un torna dove cazzo
andato trovato la sala giochi ted sembra
che abbia un piede nella fossa dobbiamo
sta bene amico mio non c'è un cazzo se
non torna quello stronzo di mio figlio
che qua un rumore che arrivava da sopra
cos'è successo
ma sono in un rifugio anti atomico e la
mia madre era preoccupata perché eravamo
in un rifugio anti atomico avete sentito
rumori che vengono da sopra con la viene
travolta giusta per controllare nel
tombino di sopra quello che è stato
chiuso per tutto il tempo che siamo
stati qui sotto ok allora si possono
usare gli oggetti e che cazzo di a1 sono
cancellati non si possono usare di end
cosa hai fatto sono morti tutti cos'è
successo e bella che sei tu moglie gioca
nella mano un orsacchiotto e o un della
zuppa in testa fatemi legge di end era
un gigante mutato in coccodrillo o un
alligatore a qualche cosa tipo con una
grande gigante bocca è un casino di
denti eravamo così spaventati parti mi
ma lui è tornato ed è salvo con noi
adesso poteva sembrare una paranoia ma
sembrava che qualcuno ci avesse seguito
la banda di bambini stavano giocando
vicino alle rovine avevano delle armi
vere e delle munizioni e stato veramente
incoraggiante vedere quei bambini dare
il proprio meglio in questa terribile
terribile situazione sono anche gelate
un pò di loro munizioni e la madonna
dolores e morta di deidratazione
l'ultima notte è anche tende e morto per
disidratazione ma che va bene ghiaccio
abbiamo provato sono morti tutti tranne
dolores che è scappata sparando ovunque
spero che sia sopravvissuto in qualche
modo si è ferito è proprio solo perito
informatico però non c'entra un cazzo
d'accordo ragazzi proviamo n'è un altro
al giusto per vedere che cosa mia figlia
che suona la tromba senti piuttosto che
sono alla tromba veli di tromba brass i
preservativi eccoli ce l'abbiamo fatto
ragazzi così preso la zuppa nella vasca
da bagno ma che cazzo serve la zuppa
meno che cosa ci faceva nella vasca da
bagno pochi ragazzi stavolta ce lo fanno
ho preso un botto dirò basta non so
quanta c'è credo e di sopravvivere per
anni cioè la madonna vietata una sala
giochi sto poste ok stavolta ci doveva
fare la mappa con qualche cosa iniziata
la vicina sia noi dall'angolo del
rifugio un ratto non in buone condizioni
abbiamo deciso di fare un qualcosa a
riguardo
dopotutto o lui o noi alla madonna col
fucile uccidiamo il ratto lega che
infetta la famiglia qualsiasi cosa fosse
morto adesso abbastanza morto e ragazzi
abbiamo bisogno di spedizione no no no
ma no aspettate a cliccare perfetto
abbiamo deciso di intrattenerci un po
oggi abbiamo giocato a un gioco due si
sono intrattenuti un pochettino con la
dama è il poker
giochiamoci la zuppa poker prof siamo
ottimisti per quanto riguarda le
spedizioni di oggi l'unica cosa
scegliere chi mandare fuori mandiamo
allo zio e quello messo meglio magari
serve essere messi meglio una spedizione
adesso potete giocare a soli dare solo
in tre niente partite a briscola in
quattro ragazzi non siamo così puliti
puzziamo e anche tanto non abbiamo il
sapone dobbiamo considerare altre
alternative cos'è questo adesso arrivate
due sono morti tutti a notte perfetto
pensavo che fosse veleno non va bene
così era uno spread per gli insetti
variamente profuma più quello che
qualche noi è la madonna è ok
non abbiamo più cibo la roba di
immondizia che si sta riempendo e
disgustosa la news buona è che non
abbiamo molto appetito guardandola
quindi salviamo del cibo come non detto
ragazzi ma se mi dicono che stanno bene
col cazzo lidl cibo ho sentito entrare
qualcuno ovvero nel siccome sta sempre
meglio e sempre mail ne ho giocato a
nascondino il più lungo round abbiamo
resistito per 10 secondi è solo perché
le luci erano spente al momento è un po
di persone sopravvissute hanno iniziato
un culto loro pensano che tutto quello
che è successo sia un gioco se persone
ci hanno dato anche del cibo perfetto
colti sì hanno deciso che non gli
serviva l'acqua santa e allora ok ci
hanno riempito due bottiglie perfetto
latte allora acqua per tutti tranne
pertini perfette per il padre padre deve
tipo guarire dieci volte col cazzo se
non dovesse bene né mary jane è perfetta
kimi è in buona salute pieno di
ottimismo il tempo di mandare qualcuno
fuori ti mandiamo e mandiamo la figlia
che non serve un cazzo di niente non
farà un metro ma proviamoci andata
giorno dove sono sopravvissuto più di
prima è già qualcosa ed esangue
dovrebbero mangiare tutti qualcosa diamo
qualcosa tutti i cacciatori mio rifugio
si sta sovrappopolato gli scarafaggi
quindi dobbiamo uccide michael fulci ma
sì ovvio come riuscirete quegli insetti
reca a casa col fucile neanche con le
scarpe pest arrivo col fucile va bene
abbiamo vinto la battaglia è la madonna
amica la guerra di [ __ ] è stata un
avvertimento per tutti gli insetti là
fuori non scherzate con noi
e sotto quale nome di contrà boccino ok
stanno tutti abbastanza bene il prego
figlia torno se la figlia tornasse ma
niente la figlia è morta quante obesa da
non riuscire a tornare giorno 16 mica
ragazzi quanto sto resistendo ragazzo ci
mette quel barile a tornare a casa dio
mio che agli anni ma si ricorda dove
l'acqua sta scarseggiando dobbiamo
farcela stava per finire la gente
abbiamo sentito un qualcuno bussare alla
porta sembrava essere un mercante che
era interessata munizioni e noi diamogli
la dama giustamente perché le munizioni
l'avete usata per uccidere gli
scarafaggi come dei deficienti diamogli
la dana katzer il meno 1 da ma siamo
spacciati ragazzi mano se n'è andato con
la dama senza darci un cazzo ma che è
figlio di [ __ ] ed sta male però non
possiamo farci niente canzoni va beh per
ora è così questo è terribile non
possiamo dormire adesso sta diventando
peggio che mai ho capito ragazzi però il
problema è che non posso mettervi tappi
per le orecchie non ce li ho che il
calcio devo fare è tornata la figlia a
cazzo come stai bene pure tu abbiamo
visto alcune strane persone guardare
dalla porta hanno detto di essere dei
maghi cosa piazza era grifondoro hanno
comprato dei calzini ci hanno lasciato
tre bottiglie per dei calzini
ma è uno di loro si è messo un calzino
sull'orecchio iniziato a ballare
certo è anche una radio perfetto da bere
a tutti e poi mandiamo quella minchiona
fuori perché non ce la possiamo fare se
non perfetto ragazzi non mangiano dal
giorno 20 salva ilva lista lama grazie
dovrebbe andar fuori vai manda mary jane
manda cela però prima che crepi di fame
ok perfetto giorno 21 sono tutti quasi
morti che io mio è tanto il giorno 21
non so abbiamo contattato qualcuno la
forza militare è fuori da qui sta
arrivando per noi tutto quello che
dobbiamo fare aspettare pazientemente
lore storno ti ammazzo io ragazzi alla
madonna accanto fate schifo quanta merda
che ci hanno posto cristiano afa sete ha
faticato affamato tutto se tendono a
mangia oggi potrebbe morire
va beh mica ragazzi siamo messi
malissimo cioè peggio di così ho dato da
bere a tutti da mangiare a nessuno non
mangiava quattro giorni è morto
perfetto ragazzi un uomo in meno da
sfamare magari si trovano solo loro e
morto nel sonno mi chiamano male anzi ce
la faremo
ce la faremo ce la faremo 25 io mi ora
sta facendo ti metti a di fare un dita
lino all'occhio del dell'orsacchiotto
devono tenerci occupati con qualcosa
prima che questo peggiori va bene brava
con solitario a manetta si spogliano con
coperta dove cazzo andata alla sorella
ce la puoi fare timi ancora una nota
esiste no è morto perché no questa scusa
cosa trovato ma dov'è andato la fame a
ha fatto diventare pazzo timi quando ha
realizzato che non c'era più provviste e
è uscito fuori non è più ritornato e non
pensiamo che dolores tornerà dalla
superficie il passato troppo tempo
bisogna fatta per 27 giorni ragazzi
fatto del mio meglio per essere la
primissima volta che ho giocato quindi
non lo so ci abbiamo provato ragazzi è
stato firma si può vincere al suo gioco
da ragazzi tanto la cosa più più wow
della storia che cazzo appena giocato
fatemi sapere se volete un altro
episodio perché nel presenti sodio
sapendo come si gioca marchio di farlo
un po meglio visto che ho capito come si
gioca comunque mi piace per la
desolazione totale perché c'è ed è per
la zuppa per la zuppa soprattutto i
ragazzi se il vino è piaciuto come al
solito certo momento mi piace mai capace
di facebook e con i video tratta
descrizione esauriti di sky
[Musica]